you
hi everyone is Jerry Aman chess calm and
I just got paired up playing a five-o
game
okay d4 c4
and I'll welcome a nympho Indian let's
play classical
mock reacts c 5d five castles something
else c5
okay
let's just develop a night
not sure what I want to do my e-pawn
just yet
okay I think I have to take now I can't
push they could take twice my night
still on the pin
so what are we going to do with the e
pond
probably III
I could go for that feels a little bit
too vulnerable f2 and the d4 square
so
to be four is too much of a bother
consider a 3 B 4 but um more so focused
on making sure I'm at least one step
away from castling I would have expected
them to play d5 a little bit sooner so
now I'm kind of
happy that they didn't go with d5 now
it's a little bit difficult to get in
okay well where's my dark square bishop
going to go I'm abandoning this idea now
two ago a 3 B 4 it's going to go with
the fee and keto and now night here I
think right now is a good idea pressure
on f6 and to do so before the bishop
gets on b7 and my queen won't be as
vulnerable on e4 so I think this is a
timely wait a timely move to unmask my
dark square bishop there should be seven
my Queen might be able to find some
residence on this square let's try that
threatening me
okay that's a serious gap right there
um
take advantage of that maybe Bishop to
d3
um yeah let's start with Bishop to d3
potentially in a fork but I don't see
how that really pans out I could still
go with Bishop here
I think I will
have a timely check on d5 I played that
really fast
my bishops are killers aren't they
actually yeah they're in a pin
so where to go with my queen where will
she be
most annoying
this might be something that will annoy
my opponent potential sacrifices on this
square they're having none of that so if
I go Knight to g5 that seems like a
sensitive point let's jump right in
there playing fast we've got to try to
keep up
position I like my king position safer
King ideally I'd like to keep the cleans
on but who knows
okay so I could win upon
Bishop takes Queen takes has to hit
otherwise I jump in here so I get the d6
pawn my only concern is that my queen
has some defensive responsibilities but
I don't think she could really be chased
away so we're going to scoop up d6 and
this should be collapsing for black
ready to double
that move identity
overlooked
taking somebody out he's not going into
the night quietly in fact that's just a
winning a move isn't it because now
Bishop takes pawn King takes I have f4
okay so this is I'm winning now a second
pawn and I will be getting the exchange
back with Queen takes or Bishop takes
I'm just considering which of the two is
better
two minutes 30 seconds so I just want to
do this as clean as possible
um
I guess we'll just go with the Queen
yep and I will soon have control over
the only open file as well yeah this is
busted for black
have to play h6 I'm not going to release
this pin well if Knight to c6 maybe I
just go straight in for it hmm I could
win a third pond
Bishop takes and then knight takes
control over the only open file shop
take and I'm not going to go forward
with taking that pond I want I want to
just make sure I keep the rook under
control
and this is how I'm going to do it
when the inch my king over is the idea
with Knight to f3 I want to limit the
counter play so we're going to sneak in
here now and they shouldn't be too much
of a bother I have a nice square that I
could post up on
in fact I think I like I think I like
going here right away and this night is
you have to play a six to save the night
okay that night is dead isn't he
they should be resigning after this move
he's a cook tonight
down to pons let's see yeah they just
resigned I don't know
I made some timely middlegame moves
there's a bit of a brief game on 32
mover but hmm what to add with this I
don't think they reacted well
I could have reacted a bit more
energetically in the center like in
reply to e3 maybe do without castle and
strike immediately with the d5 and then
takes takes Bishop is free and I have to
be concerned about a d4 push
I could take advantage my queen position
but they went with some natural stuff
and so the end result is that because
they didn't get in d5 in what I feel is
a timely way it's kind of difficult to
get it now
so in the other point is that unmasking
my bishop before the bishop is here
observing efore allows a nice transfer
just comparing the clean positions it's
it's already starting to become quite
difficult for black I mean you don't
want to play this and create holes on
the kingside and well the game move this
is not without its weaknesses I felt
that they played maybe a little bit too
fast here after I went for this
manoeuvre may be thinking fi was winning
something but this is pretty killer
and my heart kind of skipped a beat at
this moment here with Queen double
attack against the knight and rook but
I'm up upon right now and I'm picking up
this super valuable dark square bishop
soon as I
you know this 'if i've move is in and f5
is just a great number of dark square
weaknesses around the camp so there's no
way he's only worth three in this
position
he's an absolute killer
and just bring two pawns and I think
maybe the only instructive moment is
right around here and well I don't know
about that but I don't know I just
didn't want to take a third
I guess I could have I could have
captured here then something like this
takes played here and then came back to
defend d2 but okay I was content I guess
with just being up to pawns there and I
wanted to make sure there wasn't going
to be any kind of counter play on my
second rank so I could have taken that
pawn with check and returned in time
okay let's all just dive right in with
the engine and see what we could maybe
take away from the opening stage already
this is where I want to be so an Enzo
Indian classical with Queen to c2 I
don't have much experience on the wide
end playing this okay they go with c5 is
mentioned there's some other options
d5 being one of the others I developed
they developed and
yeah I think I just have to take care
they are considering III on III I think
I could end up with an isolated pond and
I don't know if I'm really so much of a
fan you know something like this
I mean you could go for it but it's just
a matter of taste I don't want to enter
an isolated Queen pond position
I like playing against an isolated pawn
more so than I do
possessing an isolated pond but okay
just took on c5 and went with III so at
this point I said that this didn't feel
right because of f2 and d4 being
available to these two pieces and in
fact Knight to g4 would have already
hurt me
so yeah III a bit more conservative
looking but it's important to neutralize
this Bishop hold this structure and
you're combating the dark square bishop
well
it suggests is dd5 right here yeah or
castles but yeah like immediately taking
action in the Senate
Bishop to e2 a6 it felt a little bit
slow
castles and it already likes me by a
little bit suggesting d5 again Queen to
e7 now but the others retreat
was maybe just too slow here up to d1
where did it really go completely
downhill I'm just getting on with
development
the three and a three I was content with
just be three Bishop to b2 I'm now just
to move away and they're a bit backward
with the development still need to open
a door and with the bishop
and yeah I mean I like my we do a let's
say queen bishop comparison I mean
they're soon going to be on this
diagonal but notice their Knight was in
the bishops way his next move was to
retreat and defend against some kind of
a fork threat that I had on e6 so b6 and
now oh I even have a 9 to d5 move Wow
that's right
cleans unprotected I have this this idea
to open up the position and in the end
what do we have this D six pawns really
weak
okay I should have I should have been on
the lookout for this I'm more I'm more
used to seeing this kind of a tactic I
guess when it's the rook that's maybe
opposite the Queen but a queen being
opposite the queen here there is a way
to take advantage of that unprotected
piece OK's Knight to d5 is better I went
with Knight to e4 still holds it as
equal
ok 9 2 D 5 noted and now F 5 they just
developed and I think it becomes a bit
tricky right around here no cling to g
4e 5
is that the top move after Queen ag4 I
mean how many other options do they have
here I probably would have gone with e5
as well this seems too scary
- giant gaps
Oh Knight to e5
ah Knight to e5 to interfere with the
main threat and at least there isn't a
weakness on the d5 square anymore well
black wouldn't be creating a weakness on
d5 so that would have been a better
defense don't budge with the pawns
Knight to e5 instead
and I went with the bishop to e49 to be
for it wants to go with you know this
just seem far too weakening is it okay
with Bishop to e4
okay with this and I think this is just
playing into my hands these guys are
monsters you know King to g7 it's not
fun you're going to be in one of one of
these two bishops will be pinning you in
some way queen g3 so I don't think I
think my opponent played so fast at this
point with Bishop to f6 I didn't really
get to voice what I may have been
threatening here on Knight to a5 I have
a shot on Knight takes e5 that's why I
draw my Queen back to g3 to converge on
e5 I'm now striking at at a third time
so Bishop f6
and yeah likes Knight to g5 play that
it's keying in on e6
and I guess they're just gone after this
next move yeah it's just a blender so I
guess the to hold the what's the best
resistance come on take out the night
that's not fun give up the dark square
Bishop this won't end well for black
can't imagine ending well with f4 right
around the corner
white having the safer King yeah there's
no cost connected with anything that
I've done here structures fine bishops
are perfect so if this is the best move
you know you're in trouble
and I'm just winning out here I should
have seen this double attack idea but uh
I guess right around this point it's
okay to know that I can at least pick up
one of the minor pieces and well he's
super valuable I took him out I could
have also doubled up apparently that's
considered better and on Bishop takes
Knight
I guess I'm crashing through oh I have
work to do seven that's right so that
was another approach to double up and
threaten this but this seemed pretty
clean too
yeah and I don't think that there's
anything more to really look at just
some opening points they didn't get in
the d5 move and towards the end here I
should be grabbing here and then Knight
g5 back to f3 there's nothing wrong with
doing that this here and in the end I'm
up three pawns sneak the King over and
welcome you know bring on the trades so
one King and pawn endgame so yeah it's
just gone from this point I didn't take
the pawn drop the king over still
holding us plus two
kingi - and yeah nothing's missed from
here just throwing some pawns my way and
now the Knights cooked
okay well a bit of a brief game
out of the nimzo-indian classical but as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this video in the comment section below
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you soon that's all for now
take care bye
you